this isn't just an act of faith it's a
moment of escape from the war and some
semblance of a more normal life
slowly in tiny but significant ways life
in kiev is returning
in the early days of the war most people
fled the city some 50 percent left
according to authorities
now some are returning and the church is
once again becoming a community focal
point
faith is the most important thing right
now more important than anything else
i've been coming here for 20 years and i
love god more than anything
i believe in my faith and with faith we
will win we all have our front lines
i am a doctor that's my wall the church
is playing its part as well for us all
saint vladimir church was built in 1882
it's witnessed much upheaval and now
it's a heritage site protected by the
city
ukraine's orthodox church was
re-established in 1990 when it was part
of the soviet union and saint vladimir
chert still to this day plays a crucial
role in society
been open throughout the war but the
last couple of sundays they have
witnessed more of the faithful coming to
pray
this could almost be a regular sunday
service but there's one crucial
difference there are more people in
uniform
there are no accurate figures for how
many people have returned back to kiev
but if you go to places where people
might gather they are actually gathering
whether it's a church like this or even
a restaurant in the middle of downtown
people are coming back and that's a sign
of confidence and defiance
inside it's a moment of reflection and
quiet belief
but as they leave the reality of a
capital city war isn't very far away
imran khan al jazeera kiev